[Music]
boom what's up everybody welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are now very grateful to have guys
saying stock on the show yeah gratitude
received and right back at you thank you
for joining us thank you
we just finished a meditation before the
show it was very brief but very nice mmm
yeah guy is what very tapped in very
tapped into himself very tapped into the
the fabric of reality I just really
enjoy him a lot as presents a lot he
helps a lot of people in a very deep and
emotional way that we hope to bring to
more people so this is what's circling
is this is what the circling Institute
does and it was initially conceived at
Burning Man when you were like oh we're
doing something pretty cool right now
and it was like let's bring this to more
people yeah yeah yeah totally
one question can I swear of course
okay cool do I get extra credit you guys
were a pickle sorry yeah sweet this is
like I'm I really am I like this whole
thing you got going here
I always got curious about like the
thing I'm curious about is just to like
you got this TV and you got the cameras
going on and you got the guy with the
like the East Coast guy that like
maturity wouldn't hug me yeah
get the lights and in the middle of like
San Francisco it's a it's an interesting
and occurs to me is an admirable
response to being alive yeah yeah I
would I would thank you mm-hmm thank you
none of this could happen without Ron
the East Coast guy that I that may give
you a handshake totally he's like a he's
like a mystic right oh he's so tapped
into he's in very interesting ways
I'm not tapped I'm I'm in prison Ted and
they laugh let's call heaven man it's
all relative exactly exactly I literally
every breath is amazing hmm so we're
like we're live stream right yeah so we
are uploading this to YouTube yes just
so I get a sense of that like who's like
who's watching us like what what what
kind of what kind of beings are like 20
to 30 year olds uh-huh yeah and so
people that are older than me yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's a nice it's a nice way to
highlight the human race put a couple
cameras on them have a couple good
conversations and you are really getting
to the deepest way that humans connect
let's let's talk about let's talk about
this circling circling Institute the
effect that this has on people I was
just blessed enough to attend your
workshop
it was an amazing workshop it was really
great to connect with people on that
level and see other people connect with
each other why don't you walk this great
is great it was great having you I would
absolutely need
I would I would love actually I would
love to hear like your take like he said
like something about with me that that
that me and circling is really tapped
into like a deeper fabric yeah yeah I
can explain that
yeah tell me tell me what you mean I
would love to so so before that I will
have to aim to explain at least the
basic idea of this but let's just say
that we sit down in a circle with a
couple other people and in that circle
we're not using our phones or not using
any technology technology's off we're
just sitting in a circle very peacefully
very calmly looking at each other and
then we will ask each other how we how
we feel and the tension of the circle
might all go on to one person at once
and this could be like a four person
circle or a 10 person circle so
everyone's attention will be on you and
I might be asked at that time how do I
feel and I might say that I might feel a
little bit of a lot of people's
attention at me at once or and then how
does that make me feel and then you keep
asking these questions and get deeper
and deeper into the moment for that
person and then you might figure out
some information about their past
they're about what they're anxious about
in the future and then you ask them why
why learn more learn more try and take
what they're saying and paraphrase it so
that they can tell that you're listening
and that you're really paying attention
so it's this process is an ongoing
process in the circle for a couple hours
usually of really deep connection to one
another and so when a guy specifically
leads it as you can imagine we have
mastery mastery is something that you
gain after a couple tens of thousands of
hours of working on something in your
life
and he has definitely become a master
and he's still learning and that's why I
love that humility and so many people do
is in the way that he guides a circle
the way that he taps into the moment and
and really knows how to be playful he's
super playful and and with with who with
the circle he's also paraphrasing really
well he's very emotive and expressive
with his eyebrows and his cheeks and a
smile in his face which is really
important because if the cosmos birthed
this human face to be this most complex
as prefrontal cortex to be so complex
then we should use it to its full
emotive potentials there was a little
glitch in the matrix right there so so
guy does a good job at that and then he
really helps people achieve
breakthroughs in in in their ability to
be just to just to be but also to
understand the moment-to-moment
interactions with themselves as well as
with other people and so then that taken
to the workplace that taken to your
family to your relationships to your
everything it just changes your life for
the better so did that do a decent job
totally like that
that described that described like the
circumstances and what you saw and I'm
curious like what like inside of that
everything that you described what what
happened in your experience like what
was the impact if there was seemed like
there was you seemed um your eyes were
like almost dilated your you were having
kind of you know spiritual tics and
totally the drool is still there a
little bit it's good yeah yeah there's I
really enjoy I'd enjoyed actually right
at the end he said something I thought
was really really particularly you like
my understanding of you in a very
concentrated way but also pointed to
something I deeply relate with and
I imagine a lot of people really do
which is this thing that where I you
know I tell me that if I if if if I'm
accurate here but where you said God man
this is hard alright so one of the
things because one of the this this
particular weekend was about the
Explorer stages circling which which is
an aspect about like not just being
circled and what will probably explain
more what that means but were you're
more of the facilitator so you're
practicing getting someone's the world
yeah and and you were like you came in
and you just you were like that was like
one of the hardest things I've ever done
in my entire life oh my god and you're
like and I and I love it yeah like do
anything to do this again and lay yeah
you're overflowing with with this set
what I would at what was inspiring for
me was it felt like that you connected
to what would make that challenge worth
it like there was something so
meaningful for you like that you saw
like you're like I want to do this all
the time all I want to do is circle
which I bet you know and I want to
explore this to you with you to today
about like what you know it's your job
and my job in some ways are very similar
ridiculously similar ridiculous mm-hmm
DQ lessly something I was thinking about
it all all through the weekend and
weekend as well yeah yeah I as I was
watching you in your art I was thinking
about how similar it was to what yeah
it's what we do so there's a difference
between being circled and doing the
circle link so when you're when you are
circled it's when the circle focuses
their attention on you and so then you
know if everyone's attention was focused
on me then then guy and other people in
the circle would be circling me and they
would be asking me how I feel they would
be paraphrasing how I feel they'd be
digging deeper into my current state of
being and then when you do circling
then guy would be potentially in being
circled and then the circle would be
circling him so then you can do it on a
one-on-one level you can do it on a five
on one level and so in this workshop it
was exploring this one-on-one level and
in the one-on-one level when you have to
be the one that really gets in the
person's skull behind their eyes in
their feeling of everything that's going
on to them that changes you can't get
distracted at all you have to be focused
you'd be zoned in but also you have to
do a great job at paraphrasing the way
that they feel because they want to feel
recognized that you're actually giving
them their full and I can just loop this
- exactly what we do on the show is that
when the person sits across from me and
they say something very complicated
about the way that they're curing cancer
I will usually take the 20 seconds after
they finish to summarize what they said
yeah and at the end when they go that's
right then they get the feeling of holy
cow what I said just landed with that
person and that same thing applies to
circling with someone paraphrase is what
no other person said their feeling and
that's a very very interesting
similarity and so when you're when
you're the person that's that's doing
the circling of someone else not only
you're paraphrasing and you're listening
listening paraphrasing and then telling
how you feel about it but you're also
trying to dig deep so you got to know
what the next best question is to ask
which is very similar to what we do on
the show as well so after I would finish
that summary about their cure for cancer
I would then also be ready to ask them
next question which is now how exactly
does that molecule affect the tumor how
does that work
yeah and then so then I wouldn't be
ready with the next question so the same
thing with circling is if the person is
talking about an emotion that they're
feeling which the emotion list is
upstairs I should have brought it down
stairs but it's this massive list of
emotions that people can feel through
the nonverbal communication yeah that I
think we were using the nonviolent
communication violent you know on
violent communication emotion list and
there's so many different emotions on
there and so you know when somebody
might be feeling anxious you will like
how does that anxious actually feel yeah
and so then a question like that and
then they have to dig and figure out how
that anxiety feels and then they might
you know so then that's this whole
process of deleting the circling and
it's very difficult to do that it's very
similar to how as an interlocutor as
something that's trying to dig deep into
the cognition of something yeah his
ability that's also it's very similar
with that overlap so I'm glad that you
bring that up and we we started packing
in this way I'm I'm feeling lots of
affinity affinity affinity me too yeah
just being here with the talking about
it like like finding the connections I
mean I felt that it was it was
interesting because the moment
Rorty she introduced us and then you you
came over and you walked in and we just
it was as if we never like we never left
each other even though we never left
look we're never even met right yeah
what do you what do you make of that
those are my those are some of my
favorite introductions because you know
when you get introduced to somebody and
it can be a little bit like you got it
kind of like scooch it your way scooch
your way into each other and then
there's also the when you meet somebody
and it's like well that there's a reason
for that yeah yeah let's hear it Ron
well you you can't dance with everybody
and I noticed I get the idea you're also
trying to you know establish a
non-violent world which I don't you know
I'm not an advocate for violence
I prefer diplomacy but you know there's
a certain sense of beauty and violence
and we can't we can't really you know I
don't wanna lose that altogether
I don't want to be dumbed down I'd like
to be nonviolent
so that oppression can mold us like clay
into something that we don't necessarily
want to be as a here in the human spirit
violence is isn't has been essential in
our development you know there's there's
all kinds of different loss my ski there
was that he doesn't want to the
oppression to be able to take its shape
on people because they don't know how to
properly fight back otally that seems to
be the oppression does not want us to
fight back it wants us to comply and
conform and and the way that you're all
loving all the time Alan I don't think
it's good you need to tap into that
darker side and exercises embrace it
love it love your hate what do you guys
what do you think yeah well I I just I
want to get that I want to get the
beauty of the beautiful when you said
it's that there's beauty and violence
sure what six I want to I want to get
that beauty and violence you know not
that let's take a scenario we'll we'll
talk about the innocence of children
yeah and there's a abused child you you
you see in an abuse child being abused
in every which way possible
and you understand that the the abuser
you know may need some loves and may
need some forgiveness but the the beauty
is in that sweet revenge for the child
in just completely annihilating to death
in a slow death unless
pipe to the oppressors head there's
beauty in that when you see a child
being abused and you stand and and you
can do something about it and pluck it
out that abuser that oppressor that
violence and fight back with violence to
annihilation finish the job that's
that's the beauty in that there's I'm
sure I am not alone in that
where others say well you know he got
what was coming to him and and I'm kind
of glad I was able to watch it just as
and the the death chamber when we per
sentence someone to death the people
want to watch the you know the person
being executed do they want they want to
watch that you know personally you know
that wouldn't necessarily be my thing
I'd rather do it myself right I'd have
you know then there'd be I'm sure
there'd be a wonderful relief in that to
fight back to annihilation Lee oppressor
so what you guys are talking about is
you have to be careful because you have
to remember there's there's a there's a
monster among us whether it's here in
the 3d reality are beyond that wants to
cook wants us to conform and comply and
use us slavery has been the big thing
since the beginning of time and as we
free the slaves they kind of just
scatter it somewhere else
so it's like it's I think what I heard
was the was the beauty at least what I
experienced was the beauty in the sense
of ultimate care with the child as a
child there was something with the child
that was like worth enough to like any
job isn't to dude not to abuse a child
but it used abusing get rid of the
abuser and make sure it's slow don't be
quick with a gunshot you know slow and
painful because that child will suffer
in its life and be taken on
choose that it necessarily would have
gone had he just been he or she just
been left alone to be a child the
innocence of a child I mean you know I'm
not a big fan of child abuse and I'm so
grateful myself that I haven't come
across it in my day-to-day endeavors to
see a child getting whacked I don't see
that and that's you know for reason
totally it's with him you talked about
like basically what I heard is like you
want to see more aggression in him like
is that what you know I don't want to I
just say he I don't think he's an
imbalance I think he's a little little
too much on the on the the light and you
know that to each his own you know he's
very diplomatic very quick to resolve an
issue and not be conflict
confrontational where I on the other
hand you know I need to let that oh [ __ ]
doesn't happen until I start screaming
and yelling and kicking and so there's
the beauty to make it should happen
seems to be now is it for him in your
estimation is it is it that he doesn't
have the other side or is it that it's
you see that it's there but somehow it's
just not expressed Jory's not tapped
into it which one is I I couldn't say
whether it is there or not in him I just
think he chooses to just lean heavy on
love and positivity
what does that that's just his makeup
chemistry I don't know why he does it he
just feels and I don't know where he's
coming from what kind of childhood he
had or so what do you make of that
everything he said was that lad he's a
very loving person
I think Ron's right he gave a really
good example a couple episodes ago where
we were I think it was with Jordan miss
Callen actually literally another circle
or Frank I love Jordan I love him too
he's like I said he's like a I would
think psychics like this Gooden is
superhero or something yeah yeah and I
love how he's all texting about it like
it's great so so Ron brings up this
example during the conversation with
Jordan where he says that oh yeah well
why don't you try and bring your
goodness to the equation when you walk
in on your brother molesting your
daughter and he was like don't you want
to just bring a baseball bat to his head
at that point and you know at that point
it's it's it's true is that there's
something that's running through you at
that moment that isn't like going over
there and trying to be like hey brother
will you come and sit down with me on
this couch and let me talk to you about
this about what you just did you my
daughter it just it doesn't work that
way right that's not that's not really
not for a lot of people yeah yeah so so
the that like within an example like
that it like I I understand like going
over there and you know like really
getting a at least aggressive with the
person and probably you know putting my
hands on their neck at least for a
little bit because that's like you're
really you're really ruining somebody
else's soul is what you're doing and you
can't ruins a child's soul that is
horrible to do all right and so at that
point like physical aggression is almost
the only thing that can slap somebody
awake from their shittiness doing that
doesn't ruin a soul but I but I don't I
don't want to kill the other person I
and I don't I don't I don't want to kill
them I think they're rehabilitator
rehabilitate people and I also think
we're approaching an age of the next
couple of decades where technology's
going to enable us to rewire the way
that people behave to where it's not
even gonna be mess
for me to exert physical force on
somebody doing that but then at any
moment when someone is doing that there
is something that prevents them from
doing it being through their neurology
that does not let them do that
and I look forward to that day when
there is no rape there is no homicide
there's none of that because when people
are wired differently and actually we
don't even need technology to do it
Swami Anand has been on our show and
he's talked about how the key to Taketa
everything is inner management and if
people just got much better at inner
management then we would live in a less
greedy less consumptive less power
driven less Fame driven less money
conspicuous consumption driven world we
would live in a much more peaceful
economist loving tranquil world that
still has creativity that still has
innovation as still as these driving
forces for good but is also not harmful
and detrimental to other people so
that's that is this idea that you
actually might not even need technology
to rewire people's minds you can just
have spirituality and meditation spent
in an inner management and help people
to where they don't need to commit these
acts so I think it's a baseline level of
like what is going on from the parent to
the child why is a child at five how do
they end up growing up in a violent
environment that causes them to want to
rape somebody or that causes them to
want to kill somebody why don't they
have their basic needs met we have so
much wealth on this plan and now but we
don't have the basic needs met for
people where they can just not have to
kill each other over money or or
violence or drugs or whatever the the
food or education or whatever it is so I
think there are plenty of other ways to
target this issue and that's I I have I
have a I do have a little bit of an
aggressive side and I and I and I and I
enjoy I do I enjoy dancing with it but I
also I I do much prefer dancing with my
quantum aside what's the thing what's
the thing that I would I could do like
the best like target I could do or
behavior or way of being with you that
could most likely bring that
like what's the aggressive side no
probably probably trying to choke me so
that I have to punch you or something
right yeah that's the vice physical
physical force against who do you think
would win in the scrap between would say
that to each other I've pushed that
these buttons in him but it's it's it's
a healthy confrontation right I I do try
to get this out of him I learned I
learned a lot from from it because if
Ron was just like me we would only learn
about what we know and this way he can
dig into some of the Quinn enmity stuff
I can dig into some of the ways that he
know it's where the yin-yang you know
he's uh Paul McCartney I'm John Lennon
you know getting better all the time and
I'm saying it can't get much worse it's
uh it's really like it's definitely
entertaining been a couple members of
our team that have told us in Ron and
I've talked about it to to to do a vlog
of the studio of what it's like on a
daily basis but we don't have them the
budget well I mean the thing I feel
impressed about it's just on patreon so
we can have the budget yeah like like
totally everybody talking or listening
right now like the patreon account this
guy's like he do an amazing work watch
the day the bout between and I should we
should have a fundraiser without you
know get the gloves put it put a rink in
here getting a selfie it's the thing
that's like the constant thing that I'm
getting actually from you is actually
how much you care about him I do very
much know like even I would imagine like
the insight of like man iord you know
like you you don't have enough darkness
going on or like whatever criticisms I
actually kind of feel and I also felt it
when you were I think I saw in the
example that you used about violence you
talked about a child right and then
protecting the child essentially so I
that's the thing that I just get right
here is just a lot of care I used
children for example because you know
what could a child have
possibly done to deserve such a thing I
can't go to bat too much for adults
because I'm not sure what happened right
around the corner you know I don't want
to I don't want to intervene in that
scenario just keep walking and I don't
know what happened but I for children
it's you know it's it's personal because
I was a child and we we will maybe all
be children again you know unless the
opry to gray gets his way that dirty rat
bastard if you're listening you better
stop what you're doing but yeah it's
life extension that scares the [ __ ] out
of me too
it's well I think for me there is
something about if I look at my life and
all the stuff that I've been able to do
and produce in the world it's made a
difference I don't think that comes from
I don't think really that comes from
some like compassionate place in me I
think it actually comes from a like a
deep sense of aggression and oh yeah I
think it's like for example and it's not
something right up front but I would I
would bet like if you just kind of like
get present there's like probably a
background hum that's going on with me
where there's the possibility like if
needed that I can be a monster me too
right the job there's a hum and that's
there's something about that if you're
miss if if somebody's blocked from that
right yeah that's not good block from
that yeah then it's hard to imagine them
getting much respect right and them
stumbling into scenarios where they can
be taken advantage of by other people
and what's great is that when it's when
it's integrated right when you're like
you get it like you're both like good
and bad like we're all evil but it's
like put it put enough pressure on us
like like enough stress turn like over
anybody and the darkest stuff can come
out of them right like it you just put a
threat enough stress over
buddy and like they'll get more
primitive they'll go back to the back of
their brain they'll fight or flee
they'll be aggressive and if if I'm if
I'm cut off from that right if I'm like
have something about like say you know
this I think this happens a lot with
with with men particularly that were
like their father was really abusive
right will they'll just see all of that
and call it bad right and then they'll
identify with being not that and then
there's there's this kind of way in
which there's almost no one they're like
they're they're maybe kind of life
supporting but they're not very life
enhancing so I like what I what I'm my
connection to what you're saying is that
there there is a really beautiful deep
deep animal capacity for violence yeah
right aggression yeah so let's let's put
it this way when I've when I've went
through my five amiyo
episodes I've had a deep sense of
aggression for being a collective
warrior for global good and that's it
was an aggression it was didn't come
from a place of compassion it came from
a place of aggression I envisioned a lot
of the terror and the crap that we did
on the planet and I was like how did I
let this happen and I was pissed and I
was like how did we let this happen and
then I was pissed and then I'm now
trying to figure out how to further
accelerate all these different ways
around the planet to to try and move
forward in a better way and totally so
that that sense of like that sense of
outrage about that like what I basically
heard you say is we have more money
and the capacity to feed everybody all
the time all the time so there's this
kind of a propyl what I'm hearing you
say is you look at that and there's a
sense of outrage that not everyone's
taken care of that sounds nuts to you
yeah right so like that I like that now
where it like I think where it goes
haywire is when it's been when it when
it goes to enrage like in rage is
something else like in rage is more like
I don't actually am not in touch with
the world I'm not in touch with a kind
of proactive openness to dissonance and
like I'm not in touch with what I value
and instead of like being outraged at
the world that mobilizes my energy and
makes [ __ ] happen and like penetrates in
those kinds of things instead like I'd
stuff it or I hide it or I repress it
and I don't know about it and then and
then one day under enough stress right
like oh like somebody says one thing to
me and I'll like shoot them or I'll like
beat someone up or I'll do these I'll be
aggressive I will be aggressive towards
somebody that were the anger actually
isn't and that's the danger and I think
a lot of that all of these killings that
are going on I I it's crazy how used to
I am of hearing that some person like
took out a machine gun and just what
haywire like that's become like a normal
thing I think that has something to do
with someone's pissed and it they're
aiming at the wrong target yes right so
like if we make that if we make the
energy if we make the energy bad or the
aggression bad I think we're just gonna
like turn we're just gonna turn it in
the wrong direction again but if you
look at anybody powerful like anybody
that like commands your respect there is
a way in which you can feel into them
and a lot of times they don't they don't
look aggressive but there's a background
homme where there's an integration of
something can we call it that though
from now
just this a background hum like it's a
tool on the tool belt that you can whip
out when you need but I don't quickly
whip out that tool I out the equanimity
tool I would whip out the peace tool I
whip out the love and the care tool and
if needed in the background there's the
other tools that are on the belt and I'm
willing to whip those out but I'm much
less it's only in these very last case
ditch scenarios am I willing to whip
those out i propelled that sense of of
gentle peace across the plate and that's
what I that's what I care about a lot I
think I think it comes with a lot of
meditation
these 10-david pasta and meditation
retreats have put me in a place where
it's it's become more of a sense of is
it's in my and maybe part of my anger
arising actually comes from knowing that
other people don't want to try
meditation so right there I can feel the
I can feel that sense of aggression or
power or dissonance yeah right can you
feel that yeah definitely is this
definitely it's like it pisses me the
[ __ ] off really it does it straight-up
pisses me the [ __ ] off there's thousands
of years of practice of a certain
technique of tuning into one's own body
in moments of time and breath and the
stupid 25 year olds running around the
planet thinking that they're too good to
try and meditate or that they need
headspace or calm or some app to learn
how to meditate that they're so
hubristic they're overly self-confident
and their sin themselves to not need to
meditate I don't need to practice that
no this is thousands of years old that
would be like saying that you know what
[ __ ] glasses there are thousands of
years old but who the [ __ ] needs glasses
I'll drink water and some other way
besides these containers no you still
use glasses because they've been around
for thousands of years so don't just
throw things away it's the limit in what
and what what are you standing for like
what are you for peace yeah for peace
totally okay so that it's connected to
peace it's difficult to understand work
I'm working on it for you it's when you
can turn that light on for us so that
Ron can get some light over there yeah
no no no leave it leave it it's no turn
it on because it'll light up let's see
how it looks then it might have dead
making all kinds of crazy acid okay
let's try thank you okay here we go
there we go no way right right you good
there yeah all right cool yeah this is
good this is good okay now back to our
regularly scheduled program programming
yeah so what do you think about the
little unpacking that just happened it's
good and he said you know he's softening
up now but you know it's all in here
it's all about balance as well I don't
want to lean to either side I want to
hold hands of both energies positive
negative aggressive or what's the
opposite word progressive I don't even
know what it is but just um
they're just energies that I don't I
want to say hi to both and say come on
let's go and do this life and get it
over with and hope nobody [ __ ] with us
so interesting is kind of watching his
demeanor like he it was there was this
kind of sense where there was like a lot
less kind of grumpiness or something or
like and he there was a kind of a like a
relaxing back even in his in his tone as
you when you look the other way I just
think that's great it all started when
you were talking about you know non non
violence you know when you were trying
to resolve problems non-violently that's
those those are triggers for me because
I I'm not sure how I mean it may work
for some but
there are some people that deserve a
[ __ ] punch to the face bottom line
that really just don't but if you train
yourself to access that tool on the tool
belt more often than you should be then
that's also a problem so there you go
so what I'm getting is like it's where
you're coming from it's what it's
connected to
like what I'm hearing it's like
basically like you're pissed off that
people aren't meditating when they could
you're pissed off about like that
there's that there we're capable of
taking care of everybody yeah right and
we're not and when you touch into that
there's something there's something in
there I liked it I liked whatever it is
that you're connected with and as you
were talking about it was really cool
like on one level I was listening to
what you're saying and then there was
this moment where I just kind of like
relaxed back and just kind of received
the being that was that was good like
that was happening in front of me and it
was just this I don't know there was
this kind of like solidarity in this
sense of strength and power and I just
noticed it like had me just kind of
relax back into myself like I'm a little
bit more aware I'm more awake thank you
I I think that you recognize that the
place of of aggression and I like how
you brought that up can actually be for
global good in there's a certain way to
access it on to a belt to do it so for
example take the earth take all of its
potential take everything that can
actually happen on it take the kids that
are that are undernourished take the
kids that are not being taught about
about morality or about their heart or
their brain or their spirituality or the
cosmos or evolution or the things that
are just basic fundamental needs for
them to move forward into a non ignorant
state of life and think about what
potential would be maximized if they
were given the ability to learn computer
science or given the ability to work on
emotion
for her emotional ethics or whatever I
would find that to be a much more
fascinating world to dig the Pacific
Garbage Patch out of the ocean to to
stop burying our garbage and landfills
too and so you know it's one thing to
sit here and armchair philosophize about
things and it's another thing to be like
no I actually know people that are
working on these endeavors that I
support and that I will go to death I
will die for this planet so there's
sovereignty to me that's that's that
sovereignty like this sense of there is
a sense of sovereignty or you could also
call it agency you can all you can call
it like the essence of individuality is
really when you think about it it's most
what most people call individuality is
actually something that I would call
counter dependence right where like I
Know Who I am
because I resist you I am that I am not
you right it's tricky because that that
looks kind of like independence but it's
not really it's a vicious form of
dependence because I need my opposite in
order to know who I am like teenagers
developmentally teenagers like are you
know that they're biologically designed
to like separate from the parents so
that they really go into that but some
people never even leave there and what I
what I'm basically hearing you tap into
is is that there's something
unreasonable in you and that's the thing
about being having a strong sense of
agency or individuality is that as my
friend Mark Lewis says he says this is
all here's the essence of agency I'm
going to medical school to be a doctor
even though my parents want me to
and I think that really put that
highlight something that that that I'm
not I'm not making anything wrong I'm
not pushing against anything I don't
have a I don't have a list of reasons or
because --is that are kind of shoring up
my position instead there's a there's a
sense of like no I'm I believe in this I
care about this because I do right
there's a solidarity in that there's a
like a it's like a deep sense of solace
nests in that and and if you look at
history as far as I can tell people like
individuals that have shift shifted
paradigms like to me they're very
they're like almost pure mythic examples
of agency Martin Luther King Mahatma
Gandhi you know people like that where
it's like you know like Mahatma Gandhi
here's a great example of this and that
open in the movie if I remember right
the scene opens and he's burning some
petition from the government he's like I
do you know I India must be free that's
what I believe and so I will not obey
and he'd like he burned some government
paper or something and he's and he walks
up to throw it in the trash and the
English people are just like what are
you doing then they come and just like
beat him up right and he falls down he
doesn't he doesn't go hey [ __ ] like
I'm gonna did it it uh no he just he
takes all that and he gets back up and
he picks it up and he walks further and
they're like what are you doing and they
just keep beating him right and then he
falls down and you keep waiting because
these these guys look like total
[ __ ]
yeah but he that is not the source of
where he's coming from where he's coming
from is he's for something he's not
against something and that is such a
rare thing and it's one of the things
that I think the circling really
cultivates is that deep
sense of individuality of like what is
it in you that's deeper it's worth
fighting for right that's only you can
bring the particular unique slant or
spark of God that kind of like comes
through you yeah that in itself does it
needed justification
right it is its own justification and so
when you're around somebody like that
what's interesting is that you could say
agency the moment there's agency is the
moment it goes to comedian right
relationship and so like a great example
of that is like you know by the end of
the movie all of India is like is like
not eating with Gandhi because Gandhi
won't like be violent he won't make
anyone wrong he's just says this is what
they believe and does not happen I just
will not eat mm-hmm right in that sense
of non-violence see see that's a level
of like integrated aggression and almost
like a transpersonal level and but but
notice what happens is his singularity
created like like the whole movement
same thing with Martin Luther King if
you ever watch that from the angle of of
agency and you look at it as like almost
like a pure example of it he's just he's
like I have a dream and that
[ __ ] is like you could just feel
him connected the earth noises come at
us boom and then it turns around and
then there's like thousands of people
right agency goes to communion and if
you don't have a strong sense of agency
you can't be in a relationship with
other people
Yeah right you'll be constantly correct
looking to them to define you right
you'll always be in a sense of
instability will either merge with them
you'll be against them you'll like yeah
you got it
you're right about the for the for
something and the being for something
and having a sense of agency around that
even to go as far as to say that even
kanye west just message to just tweeted
about it online which was that if you
have incredible foresight stay stubborn
and that I think is a lot of what the
people that you listed have is agency
and foresight and then knowing how to
just stay stubborn to that thing and to
not be molded by these external forces
around you and circling does I like how
you called it the spark or the slant of
God through you what is it like okay the
evolution the cosmos birthed your
nervous system
what is that spark of the cosmos that's
running through you and how your heart
and your brain in your mouth every
single day if you don't know what that
sparker that slant is we will help you
find that spark or slant you will find
it in yourself but we can help teach
these interesting strategies that have
been taught for a long time again
meditation for thousands of years in
order for you to better figure out what
you love doing every single day where
the value you want to bring to the world
and you know creativity is one of the
best ways to do that in creativity's
right now kind of out war because of the
9 to 5 the 9 to 5 is kind of killing
creativity in many ways but and a lot of
children are not able to express their
creativity because of the way that you
know even on the last episode we were
just talking about how parents have even
scheduled out children's times to go do
all these things and that the kids don't
even have the availability to think for
themselves like the shower thoughts
accessing the parts of your brain when
you're just in the default state so so I
agree with you about agency and I think
agencies crucial I think circling does a
good job at that
maybe we should now loop loop back to
what we were talking about yeah I knew
what you were gonna say was I was asking
about is like so you described look kind
of like what happened some of the things
that happened encircling what was how
did him talk to you like how did you see
impact
people like how is it how did it ride
through your nervous system and what did
it have you think and what have you feel
and what did it have you imagined and
like what was the what was the
experience you created in you you know
the you know the relation you know the
relationship when you walk up to someone
and you just say like you're maybe at
your you're at the checker you're at the
checker stand or get the cashier stand
and like here's my thing hi how are you
good how are you good
here's my card paid done you've left
circlings the exact opposite of that
circling is the literal opposite of that
it is the the most deep dive into
someone else's life that you can
possibly achieve and I think it's even
deeper than a marriage with someone you
can get married and you can circle with
your partner for your whole life and you
can get really deep with them totally
but I think there are many people that
don't even have the ability that have
that have been married for 20 years that
have never went as deep as they do when
they go and sit down to circle yeah and
so just because of that by itself is
that's what's mind-blowing so so for me
seeing people in the state of the
deepest surrender vulnerability I cried
I cried for others I cried for myself I
love crying I think crying is not a bad
thing at all I think everything you see
in the news about never crying and about
being a warrior and about only being a
warrior and pulling yourself up by your
boot sout of poverty and going and
crushing it into the world I think that
that's all it's all a little bit too
much of a story for for you to forget
about everything else
and everything else is the crying it's
the emotions the vulnerability it's the
feeling it's all of these different
feelings that you can experience and
access to and be in the moment of that
we that we typically don't access enough
of than each other and when you do want
to go and and bring something to the
world it's not about just pick yourself
up and go and do that thing it's really
it's more so about what is the world
around you how is the world built around
you to help you actually achieve that
thing because if the world is is
literally around you you can zip code
literature is so solid you can be born
in pack Heights or you can be born in
Southside Chicago there's a big
difference in life outcome and so if
you're you there you go it's just it's
that much more difficult to get out of
Southside Chicago to become somebody
that is self actualized and that is
bringing value to the world than it is
when you live in a ten million dollar
house it's just completely different
tracks of self-actualization and ability
to to achieve something and so the
environment around the person if we're
constantly going and saying hi how are
you good okay thank you bye versus like
no how do you feel how do you feel and
exploring that and waiting on it and
being patient with it and paraphrasing
how somebody feels you the amount of
times that conversations end in today's
world because people don't know how to
paraphrase people don't know how to ask
the next level of depth of question is
just egregiously high so you'll have guy
tell you you'll be like I just came back
from New York and then your response
will be oh cool I've been in New York
before okay great that's sure that's a
way to have a conversation there's also
the way of being like oh you were just
in New York what were you doing there
what did I just do I brought you a level
lower
deeper into your journey into what you
were doing what were you doing in New
York
oh I was I was attending a summit
learning about education oh cool
why do you care about education going
deeper again
what's your emotional draw to education
how do you feel when you think about
education these deeper and deeper levels
of questions that you can get to in
somebody and sure you might not have
time when you're trying to get a coffee
to ask somebody what impact they want to
make in the world but but I promise you
that if you at least aim to do it more
often
and have that type of more intimate time
with people at these deeper levels that
that same ability of connection will
apply to every single one of your
relationships including your family your
work your partner your even the person
that's making a coffee so which will
soon be a robot it already is a robot
but uh yeah totally yeah so get
retrained basically we've talked about
that okay absolutely need some more
water
I noticed that yeah thank you thanks
make your own yeah that thing when you
said going kind of dropping levels of
depth and basically how you listen with
to somebody so circling is here's the
thing I just really want to emphasize it
cuz there's a lot of different ways to
like describe what it is but a but the
thing I want to just get really like
make really clear that it's you don't do
circling to get good at circling right
you do circling because what is to like
is to develop or access or deepen a
particular aspect of being a human being
right such that when you're not circling
right you can you that your baseline is
just more relational right there's
there's more of a permeability there's
more of an openness there's more of a
like a a pre reflective sense of
belonging right a sense of curiosity
like a vulnerability to be awestruck a
vulnerability to be to have the things
in the world grip your attention to
shine forth and that is really why you
want a circle and so there's there's
different ways that it looks right but I
you know I want to just kind of go back
a little bit and like talk about a
little bit how it started because this
is it's really I mean it's a little bit
like it's a little bit like being and
it's like a Twilight Zone or something
being me right
we had no I liked I had no intention in
doing something called circling I had no
plans on it I didn't have any ideas
about it I didn't even know that there
was a thing that I ended up being
somehow gifted at a particular angle of
it like I didn't know any of that stuff
Burning Man met my friend Jared
Candelaria walking out on the playa
somebody kind of went off Jerry's kind
of this we was this kind of
neurotic care like deeply heart like
deeply heart based beautiful being that
was also just it's just neurotic and
kind of controlling and but uses bit he
was a big energy and so we're walking
around and he wants to keep everyone
together right and then so that you know
like day via his name was CJ back then
those were running off into the sex camp
right and so I could just instantly feel
Jerry's like every stinker in his body
kind of pulled in and there goes Damien
I was like alright we got to go pull him
out so we you know we get into the sex
camp we find him bring him back out and
so we end up way beyond in the middle of
the desert we couldn't even see the
lights I think this is not I can't
remember if it was 96 or 98 it was one
of the two I'm terrible with dates but
he was 90 day yeah and we yet we we
ended up just like a like a classic
Burning Man Playa experience we're in
the middle of nowhere here all of a
sudden is this bizarre art kind of like
spiral teepee thing right and so we just
go inside if when we sit down in a
circle and you can feel you could feel
the dissonance you could feel the
conflict in the air and I just started
getting interested in the conflict I
started into like what's you know what
what is this kind of thing going on and
at a certain point before I even we even
recognized it like the the conversation
or the interaction left the level of the
conflict and then ended up going on I
undermine and there was just a way that
Jerry and I and everyone there started
relating to that particular moment in
such a way that we all had this
experience of whatever it was about
Damien that makes Damien Damien like
like all the veils like all the veils
kind of like peeled back and whatever
that was kind of shine forth and it was
utterly stunning yes it was absolutely
stunning and it's like a feat that
particular feeling even if you have it's
one of those things that and I think
everybody could probably like knows what
I'm talking about even if you've never
had this experience you just kind of
know it where even if you've never
experienced that experience before
there's this quality of when you do it's
a deep recognition yeah right it's like
because it's something so so close into
being a human being that there's just a
stunning beauty to that spark of God if
for lack of a better word you know and
and so what ended up happening is is is
when you take that to everybody
well well here's what's interesting is
that there was just spontaneously of
course that was the thing I got
interested in and that's what the thing
that everybody got interested and we
just started following that and it just
naturally went to the next person and we
and again there's like as this is
happening it's like I wasn't there
sitting at a finger by like boy that
we're going through an interesting
process right now no it was this like I
was gripped something was had my
attention and time disappeared and then
went to the VEX and it's something
similar the next person and what to the
next person the next person but also
uniquely different to the way that God
comes through them yes totally
and afterwards basically for all
intensive purposes like Jerry comes up
to me he's like we stopped in its like
12 hours later right and it's now the
sun's coming up right 12 hours totally
totally time disappeared yeah and he he
looks at me and he's like he points back
to that where we were and he's like that
no it's like yeah that we never word for
it but we recognized something and I was
like that and at some point we both of
us just stopped
and we just put our hands out and we
just committed to whatever that was we
were just gonna bring it out of the
world and that's basically was the
handshake that I had no idea that that
was going to be that was gonna change to
direct not only the trajectory of my
life but it was gonna change it was
gonna change mile my understanding of
even who I was and what life was and
what being was I had no idea and I would
say that I'm still for me I'm still
learning about what we were pointing to
I'm still learning about it yeah exactly
I said most of the time when we're
circling I think what I'm doing is I'm
like what are we doing what is this
thing that's happening there's something
so alive about it yeah that it's gripped
my attention and it and and in paying
attention to it and in being interested
in it what it's taken to be interested
in it is a transformation of myself like
is a is a deepening of my own of my own
attention my ability to pay attention my
ability to see my ability to like make
distinctions my ability to open my heart
like going what because if you look at
something really really profound enough
to really see it the seeing needs to be
of enough profound enough of a seeing to
be able to apprehend it so there's this
for me circling is this experience of a
deep kind of listening a deep kind of
seeing there is really tapped into the
like that the most real thing that I can
think of or experience in the universe
like called another human being if you
think about it
I think about this all the time I'm
constantly thinking about this is on one
level what you know when we circle these
are the what we're doing if you kind of
like we were flying the wall you see a
bunch of people sitting together and
then just basically bringing our
attention on each other and sometimes
just one person and then out of that
this everyone kind of walks away
awestruck changed like all these crazy
things happen they have these deep
realizations all this kind of stuff
there's something going on in an
individual that I don't think it's like
the individual is is is sacred I think
the individual is the sacred and that's
it that's and I think that that's why
when we when we just really bring an
open attention about what is right now
with each other what exactly are we
bringing our attention to well if you
think if you really think about it as
far as my understanding is like the most
complex thing that the universe's ever
produces is this is this like the
cerebral cortex right it's the most
complex thing in the unit the most
sophisticated the most complex part of
the known universe as far as we can tell
so on some level what I'm looking at is
the most special part of the universe
the most articulated the most real like
the most realized in fact it's you could
say human beings seemed to be the place
or the most vulnerable place where you
could say the cosmos thinned itself out
enough to the point where it thinned
itself out to itself and it could
recognize itself yes and that
recognition is all right here it's all
right here
and there's an if you just look at it
there's I think everyone knows that
experience of well we would do these
like an advanced courses we really kind
of refine this and study this you know I
could look at I can intensely look at
that class I can't instantly be with
that flower or a wall or even like an
animal or a tree but if I look at
another in the eye there is something
that goes on there that is unlike
anything else in the world yeah right
and whatever that is
it seems to be something like an
experience of pure non neutrality
there's like a like a a a sense of a
sense of of existential obligation in a
certain sense there's anxiety that comes
up there it could be tear there comes up
there could be beauty there could be but
but but it's anything but it's anything
but neutral it's anything but
indifferent so like really make eye
contact with somebody and be with
somebody I still I don't think we
understand what we're actually seeing
but if we stay with that and we keep
looking and we keep looking with our
eyes with our ears with a heart and we
just keep feeling into what is it who
are you who am i with you like what's
happening is we are together and we keep
looking at that the we end up having
these like life-changing moments and so
I don't exactly know why that is but
there's a but what it's what it's done
for me and for a lot of people in my
life is it seems to be it seems to open
up a deep sense of wonder right a deep
sense of wonder and a deep sense of
humanity and a sense of like a a wanting
to drop in with people an interest in
people
right yeah what's it like to hear all
that for you
the stretchy stretc oh the the sacred
the sacred yeah not just sacred but the
sacred yeah inside of every skull that
in body that the cosmos is birth that
now we can then reflect on not only how
we got here but also who we are yeah and
then the next step is where are we going
and I I break down the cosmos and
evolution and consciousness and futurism
in this way because I think these three
pillars of evolution consciousness and
futurism I think these three things
together are basically what what was it
was it evolution consciousness and
futurism because this is the cosmos burb
burb first birthing from Earth and
birthing like that and then now we look
at each other in this very complex way
knowing look at a glass you see nothing
look at someone else's eyes you see
everything and there's a very very huge
difference between those two things and
it almost puts people into an
uncomfortable fate state to look at
other people in the eyes yeah and then
the conversation about where are we
going with futurism is really important
because if we don't have a game plan
yeah we're gonna experience a
potentially a species extinction and you
kind of we kind of want our kids to live
on so just to tap into more of what you
were saying yeah I do think that what's
going on between people is you can't you
can't put words it's so difficult to put
words on the description of it but to
tune into those finest moments of being
the most fine moments in its deepest
nuance and its deepest complexities yeah
and that long process that it takes
overlooking I mean for me what I felt
while you were speaking was I felt
really relaxed I felt very much like you
were speaking on behalf of of everybody
that's ever wanted to voice their
opinions about how complex it is to try
and talk to another person and so that's
kind of what that's kind of what
circling does and it does a lot of
things like you said but and you know
when people leave our show and say that
that was the best interview I've ever
been that's the best conversation I've
ever had that's I felt so alive I felt
like I could be myself felt like the way
that I was communicating was great
because it was amplified by you that
those sorts of moments for me are my
most alive as well because then I get
the chance to or some of my most life
because then I get the chance to feel
what it feels like for someone else to
have one through a period of time with
me feeling like they were able to
communicate better
these wisdoms that they have about
different aspects of of existence and
that's very similar to what you do a
circling and you know I I really
appreciate the thing that you said about
you know when people walk away and they
say they say like god that was the best
interview I've ever had or but in some
way they feel impacted or changed or
have a different perception of
themselves or what they're doing think
what that I think what that highlights
is this is this thing that I think that
really at the base of it is really what
circling is practicing which is a like a
radical kind of listening and it's
interesting when you think about it that
listening it's funny there's lots of you
know if you go to the bookstore there's
lots of stuff about communication right
there's lots of books and information
about communication and obviously there
is because like it's really clear or
like to be a good communicator is almost
everything right if you can't
communicate you can be brilliant and
like you can be amazing but if you can't
relate with other people there's no way
that you can
that'll make any difference in the world
however usually I think when people
think about communicating they think
about talking right they think about
saying the right thing but there's
something there's something and I think
that it's missed points is a hint on its
nature which is listening is that
ontologically speaking like listening is
the is prior to speech like speech right
just doesn't somebody doesn't talk and
then in here shows up no there must be a
listening that calls forth speech and my
experience has been is like if you
really really learn how to listen like
really listen you know you don't have to
worry about what to say because all
speaking is a function of listening so
like right now I'm speaking to the like
in some way I you're listening shaping
what I'm saying like all the things that
you bring to bear all the frameworks all
the things that I can be aware of and
then I'm not aware of that you're aware
of them nah I'm not aware of that are
shaping me saying this thing right now
in this moment is is really a function
of your the depth of your of your
listening and if in to get kind of like
to kind of draw on that a little bit
closer to home if we think about it how
the hell do we end up with an identity
right on the most basic level like how
do we know that were a person and that
were we have a name in a first name and
a last name and we have a nature and a
personality we only know that through
the network of relations that we we were
born into yeah
you know you could say that like I am I
am of in a function of the gaze that
grew me yeah right like the quality of
attention in my household when I was a
kid to whatever depth that it like depth
or lack of depth was able to see
whatever was was true and me and call it
out and then speak it to being a relate
to it in something about in that in that
interaction constituted myself and
what's interesting is like I it's it's I
think it's hard to comprehend to what
degree like that we fundamentally don't
understand that in how we conceive of
relationships and a good example of that
are dating sites okay I don't have
anything I don't have any problem with
dating sites I think dating sites are
cool I've never used them of course I've
never pretty much never been single I
was married for 15 years and in a
relationship for the last seven but but
it's interesting because their dating
sites have have a they presuppose what a
human being is and it's like if you
think about it they look at human beings
as kind of like a thing a hunk of stuff
with qualities that you can measure and
they're like all right if we take this
hunk of stuff when we are able to
measure the quality isn't just the right
thing and figure out the algorithms and
we connect those things together then
you get they're gonna join together and
then they'll live happy forever after
but what the thing the thing that that's
really ignorant to is to what to what
degree that actually if we get into a
relationship I will be caught like Who I
am will be constituted through that
relationship yeah and we all know that
right we all know that like we've had
friends all of the fat friends have been
impacted by people both positively and
negatively that fundamentally shaped who
we are and I would say that circling
really sees that and takes that really
seriously of like in a certain way
there's a of like where we really learn
how to deeply listen and be with you as
you are Martin Martin Buber the Jewish
philosopher theologian the
existentialist he really I think points
to it in a profound way
and the way he would put it is that that
said that you know he said that human
beings
existentially speaking are our relation
right you're always in a relationship
with your environment with other people
like with your clothes with your
thoughts there's no such thing as a sole
proprietorship or a thing that then
relates know you are a relationship and
the way he puts it is that there's that
you're in one of two relations called an
i thou or an i it and he said that i
thou and i ate or spoken as one word
right so there's no like i without a
dower in its and there's no it without
an i and there's no doubt it I that
there are relation so there one word and
he said and this is I really I really
like the way that he the way that this
makes the world kind of come forward he
says like when you're in when I see you
isn't it what that what that means is
I'm seeing you as a means to an end
right like or when I see that Cup like
for example that cup is an it I see it
as a means that my end of drinking but I
can also like look at you and see you as
a means to my my own ends of needing
approval right or I can see you as a
means to my own end of being liked or I
can see you as a means to to an end on
some level that like like I you're
you're an it but then he said what's a
lot rare but as possible is an i thou
relationship and and I thou is where I
see you as an end in yourself and you
can kind of feel that right you kind of
feel that sense of like even like right
now it's like if I just it's like if I
just kind of see you as a though it's
like that there's something in other
words there's something that's
fundamental about you there's something
that's displayed in you that
will I is on some level as mysterious is
is endless and is an end in itself like
for its own sake
right as I like see you that way you can
it take some different I arises with
that right it's a different I that can
see you as a vow and there are those
moments where it's like where for me
it's this experience of where you look
like the like the smallest little grain
of sand like you see the whole world
like that's you could say that circling
in in a real in a real way is an I thou
practice right like how do we sit and be
with each other and like and like really
really pay attention yeah and as we say
be with what is right and it's funny and
I think you kind of like you spoke to
like how difficult that is to do
surprisingly difficult that is to do
just to be with you as you are as it
happens without trying to improve it
without trying to solve it without
trying to fix it because in all those
ways and you can feel at the moment you
do it like I constitute you as an int
and there's something else going on
there right so like withdrawing that and
just returning to like being with what
is like what's happening with you right
now that really resonates we think about
how we frequently try and see someone
else as a means to something that we
want and then also think about how we
try and problem-solve everything
everything yeah and we don't and when we
when we see you as an end in the way
that you are at this moment into the
next moment we just try and explore and
dig and understand and relate yeah
and communicate rather than try and
solve and think about the future and how
can I help and then you're then it's
different
and it's like if he if and this is where
if circle you can look at circling is
like a methodology you could look at it
is like you know a prac it's a practice
and if you look at circling as a
practice you you could say it's like um
[Music]
just like any practice right yoga for
example like you go and do these intense
stretches like these concentrated
stretches and like you're you're like
stretching and you're adjusting and
you're like fine-tuning these poses and
like you're training your mind and
you're consciously moving towards
discomfort and you're changing
relationship that discomfort and you're
doing that not so that you can do that
particular pose well it's so that when
you're not doing yoga and you're walking
outside your fundamental baseline is
more open and that's exactly what you
were mentioning I totally agree and
that's kind of a meditation does it's
not so that you can just be you just
changes your cadence every single day
and circling change your cadence and
your relationships with people in the
way they view people and that's the same
way that any really mastery does is it
changes the way that you kind of behave
through the flow so alright we have a
lot more to unpack and talk about but I
know that we have to be kind to our just
uh just a time and we'll we can do more
right now
it's 5:22 now but but we can still we
can still ask you just one one question
and then we'll do more conversation soon
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world
it's like
it's funny like what I actually think is
the most beautiful thing that in the
world is the ability to see the most
beautiful thing in the world is in my my
my girlfriend Brianna who I'm like so
profoundly in love with it's like crazy
she's like guy you have Beauty eyes and
she always says that and I'm like I I
love that I love that I actually think
that that's the thing that's the most
beautiful thing for me is when I see
people have a seeing that can like see
the deepest most profound in the most
particular and minut like the ability to
see beauty itself I think it's beautiful
and and I think that's what like I think
my my life seems like it seems to be
dedicated to right is to be able to be
more to be continuously more vulnerable
to being continuously awestruck to be
vulnerable to to moments of beauty and
the most simplest and inner interaction
the most simplest thing and there's
something about to gesture and like see
somebody and open your gaze in that way
and invite them in to a dialogue it's
just like what you're talking about
could just be with the guy in the
grocery store where those there's that
moment where we share something and
that's the thing I'm curious about like
if we like right here there's you and I
here and like we're connected can you
feel a connection yeah what is it well
like what is it that we're sharing like
what is that thing that we're sharing I
think it's a little bit more of a gentle
touch it's a different vibration
it's a deep mystery to me yeah deep
mystery but it's very easy to recognize
when it's there you know when two people
are arguing on like CNN or Fox News and
they're not even giving each other like
any love or generosity or patience or
anything we're the exact opposite of
that right now
this Masek makes me think about
something that Heidegger talked about
I've always really an appreciated he's
and Andrea for me is the other thing
about circling circling he's very deep
it's not psychology it's more of a deep
lived kind of philosophical practice
that deepest sense like the sense of
like we're knowledge because at a
certain at a certain level like
knowledge itself becomes love right
knowing is becomes the experience of
love and he says that and how he puts it
as and I think it was a lecture he did
at the at the anniversary of the death
of some of some like extraordinary
physicists and so he gets up there and
he says good you know if if we were to
if we were to look at a grand painting
right I knew we were to see it we should
we should look at it for a long time and
be patient and not demand that it be
immediately intelligent intelligible
it's like and if the poet right if real
goers were here in the person right and
he were to read his poetry we should
want to we would want to hear it again
and again by the poet himself and again
without much protest we wouldn't demand
that it be immediately intelligible to
us right it kind of goes into like yeah
and and if the scientist were here
explaining his
series of like cosmic unity or whatever
that like to people in the audience that
most would comprehend anything that he
was saying yet again we should still not
demand that it be immediately
intelligible and he just goes on and he
says so let me give you a hint on how to
listen to the lecture and I love this he
says that if listening away if you
refrain from listening to the lecture as
a series of propositions we can begin to
follow the movement of showing if we can
Lex and that's the really important
thing is a kind of openness that doesn't
presuppose the world yeah right because
I think a lot of people I think a lot of
people are walking around with a bunch
of presuppositions that they're not
aware of and they don't notice that
they're constituting the world in terms
of what they think yeah right now
decreases their open-mindedness which is
one of the reasons why we have so much
polarization and bias and what he's
saying is that and this is really speaks
to my own experience of what it's been
like being with people the impact that
it's had on me of like really deeply
relating to people is that when you when
you engage with another it's almost
instant access to what be what is beyond
what you can think like you and I could
sit here for a thousand years and I can
like ask you tons of questions and you
can tell me everything that you know
about yourself and we'll never reach the
bottom of you and that's and that's a
lot of what we will be we have dived
into today that's a lot of what we will
dive into moving into our next
conversations I am so grateful to be
able to sit down with you guy and I'm
grateful to do a circling here on Monday
and our studio that's gonna be a lot of
fun I'm gonna bring a lot of people out
you come and sit down will do it'll be
fun to like just see it see it live see
you live we'll do some conversation off
screen we'll do some conversation
on screen you guys will get to see what
that's like right here on Monday evening
and thank you very much for tuning in we
appreciate you so much
Cher's concert with other people if you
enjoyed the idea of knowing how to tap
into this moment and diving deeper into
the the conversations will put circling
Institute link in the bio to check them
out give us a like it was a comment tell
us what you think smash that subscribe
button join us in the movement to
rebirth the public intellectual and to
inspire people to build the future
across all these different domains join
us on patreon we need your help
we need to fund the studio fund our
electricity our internet all everything
we need help on hit that patreon hit
they hit the patreon button we'd greatly
appreciate you joining us thanks to our
producing partner Ron Vargas greatly
appreciate you guys for tuning in and
we'll see you guys soon peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]